on prime crime tonight the mystery
surrounding a young mother
nothing that happened she was not with
us disturbing secrets
come to light just had was probably the
most erotic experience i've had in my
entire life
and an ending so shocking it haunts
people to this day
but i think i need help right away
good evening everybody i'm jesse weber
and welcome to prime crime tonight this
is where we do a deeper dive into the
most high profile and memorable true
crime cases
tonight a beautiful family torn apart by
devastation
it's kind of blurred actually i'm just
kidding
[Music]
josh powell and susan cox's story began
like many others
a young couple falls in love and decides
to wed in 2001
they moved to west valley city utah and
then welcomed the births
of their two precious boys charlie and
braden
while on the outside everything may have
appeared to be picture perfect
the cracks began to show we saw
red flags we felt he was very
domineering or spoke so much we felt the
red flags but not
as real serious in the very beginning
it it as the time went on we
felt there could be some problems i
think a good way to describe it is we
saw the tip of the iceberg
and we had no idea how much more iceberg
there was underwater
susan confided in her friends about her
fights with josh
and how she wished the two could seek
counseling in a letter to loved ones
dated june 28
2008 susan would reveal a darker side to
her husband
explaining that she no longer trusts him
and warned how if something happened to
her
it may not be an accident even if it may
look like one
the next month susan records an eerie
video
this is me july 29 2008
it is 12 33 mountain time
um covering all my bases making sure
that
something happens to me or my family or
all of us that
our assets are documented hope
everything works out and we're all happy
and
live happily ever after as much as
that's possible
on december 6 2009 after attending
church services and spending time with
her neighbor
at around 5 p.m susan decides to lie
down for a nap
after reportedly not feeling well josh
would say
he and his boys went out to go sledding
this would be the last time
anyone outside of that house saw susan
again
in the very beginning i didn't realize
how
serious it was and within three or four
days
of her missing they felt it was a
homicide
and then i realized that this was really
happening
when charlie and braden aren't dropped
off the next morning for daycare
police are contacted law enforcement
burst into the powell home
and discover no one is there the crime
scene was interesting because when the
police came in they found
an attempted cleanup of blood on the
floor near a couch
they saw fans blowing in order to dry
the blood
they saw her purse was in the house with
her wallet
and her keys were later discovered a few
hours later
josh and the boys returned home he
claims the three traveled 25 miles away
for a camping trip in the desert
along the pony express trail which is
odd
considering the frigid temperatures at
the time
even stranger josh had susan's phone on
him
with the sim card removed during
questioning at the west valley police
station
josh adamantly tells investigators he
doesn't know where susan is
but in another room a detective speaks
to young charlie
he says susan came with them on the trip
but didn't come back so your mom stayed
at the park
where did she stay at the park
do you know where she stayed
at dinosaur national park do you know
where at the park
no no see my mom
stayed wear a
it's not entirely clear what charlie was
referring to or if he was just using his
imagination
one theory is that perhaps charlie was
referencing the dugway
geode beds an area filled with
specialized rocks that contain
crystals not only had the powell family
actually visited this location a year
earlier
but curiously it's also near where josh
says
he and the boys had camped out one of
our detectives just
interviewed your children and your
children are telling
our detectives that mom went with you
guys last night
and then she didn't come back
she did not go with us well
with that just getting that information
you're not gonna go anywhere i'm not
gonna let you leave there's one that
knows
nothing that happened she was not with
us and if my kids said that
do your kids lie then do your kids lie
sometimes they do
i mean if they said that she was with us
they know that's not true
so if they said that she was with us
then
i guess that would put her out in the
out the
pony express okay and that's my concern
investigators conduct a search of the
desert
but find no evidence that josh and the
boys went camping
yet there was a mine located 30 miles
away
that reportedly was doused in gasoline
and
set on fire interestingly josh allegedly
told a work colleague on a previous
occasion
that the best place to dispose of a body
is down a mine shaft
i believe josh killed susan because he
wanted an easy way out
the relationship was suffering she had
already conveyed to family members that
there was no more romantic interest he
didn't touch her he didn't hold hands
with her
there was nothing happening physically
in the relationship there was a lot of
infighting
and i believe that was an easy way out
for him instead of dealing with the fuss
of child custody and child support
susan's body has never been recovered
whatever happened that night he got rid
of her
and he's he was adamant that well i did
i wouldn't kill her i didn't i don't
know which uh
you know i don't believe for a minute i
know that
had he not drugged her or poisoned her
that and even one-on-one it'd have been
a
the neighbors would have called in
suspicions didn't fall on josh alone
i think josh had help from his family
i know his brother michael had helped
him i didn't know that at the time i
thought it was probably stephen josh
together
police believe josh's brother michael
may have played a role in disposing of
susan's remains
especially after a cadaver dog picked up
the presence of human decomposition in
his trunk
but further tests were not definitive in
2013
michael committed suicide josh's father
stephen powell
is a whole other story in the years
after susan's disappearance
stephen and josh would conduct a smear
campaign against
her claiming she ran off with another
man and
threatening to release her diaries but
in 2011
the truth behind stephen powell came out
as he was arrested and charged with
voyeurism and child pornography
evidence collected by authorities showed
josh's father was
obsessed with susan and would
continually
lust after her i just had
was probably the most erotic experience
i've had in my entire life
i just i hate to say it i mean of course
because i haven't had that many
experiences but
susan has been feeling ill she had a
cold
and i offered to rub
her feet to rub her toes to give her
some
stimulation started massaging her legs i
would have loved to go all the way up
her legs but i did do her calves
because her feet were resting in my
crotch so i
sort of rubbed her calves steven's
fantasies
he imagined that his daughter-in-law
would reciprocate those feelings
i mean i know she she couldn't have
missed it she's not naive either i know
from what i've read in her journals
that girl is not naive in a recorded
conversation
steven eventually professed his love to
susan
but he didn't get the response he wanted
for example when we were sitting on the
couch it just felt like you were
very um you know i mean
i was extremely aroused and i think you
were somewhat involved
at least i thought i don't know where
you're going with that
susan i
the scariest part josh and his two young
sons
had been living with stephen in seattle
when susan went missing
and then when he moved into his father's
house which is the one place she did not
want her children
to be because she knew about the father
i she didn't know the depth of the
father's depravity but
she knew that she didn't like the father
and didn't want her children around
him after his convictions on the sex
crime-related charges and serving
several years in prison
stephen's released in july of 2017 but
dies the following year from a heart
attack
taking with him any secrets he had about
susan's whereabouts
despite motive opportunity and
circumstantial evidence
josh powell remained a free man i don't
believe
josh powell was arrested earlier simply
because they did not have a body
in a lot of cases across the country
depending on jurisdiction
no body no prosecution is kind of the
rule of thumb when we come back the
story is about to take a turn
and it's a turn that no one could have
expected
this could be life-threatening he went
to court on wednesday and he
he didn't get his kids back
charlie and braden know what happened to
their mother
much more than they were allowed to say
and so i think josh was afraid of that
and he knew his time was about he was
backed into a corner
susan cox powell disappeared in december
2009 and her body has never been found
and as if that wasn't tragic enough
something is about to happen
that changed everything after susan
vanished her husband josh
powell though never arrested remained a
person of interest in the case
susan's parents chuck and judy cox
pleaded with the state to not allow
their son-in-law to have custody over
his boys
charlie and braden but the state
disagreed
they were saying well don't worry we got
this we got your back
we're going to take care of these kids
we're going to help out here
but you know we have to go toward
reunification
and when they were going along those
lines and it was clear that they were
ignoring us
and and listening to josh and trying to
work that
in spite of the fact that their mother
is missing
which they came out with well that's not
domestic violence just because the woman
goes missing
you take the children away from their
mother and
i said well he hasn't been arrested he
hasn't been charged
however after josh's father stephen whom
the three had been living with in
seattle
was arrested on child pornography
charges a state court took the boys away
and granted the cox's temporary custody
josh though was a loud visitation
they went before a judge just a handful
of times in this case
they took the kids into protective
custody they decided to
allow visitation and recommend that to
the judge they didn't have to give
visitation
they haven't found these kids in a house
of horrors i mean they were there's a
news hanging from the ceiling there was
gallows one of the brothers ran around
naked
there was pornography all over the house
and the grandfather who had an obsession
with with
susan was arrested and the kids were
taken
so they could have said no visitation at
all but they were just
really trusting us and talking to us
and then they started to say things that
were kind of
disturbing and they were starting to
remember
things and that really scared josh
[Music]
hey i'm on a supervised visitation for a
court-ordered visit
and something really weird has happened
the kids went into the house and the
parents the biological parents whose
name is josh powell will not let me in
the door
what should i do it's 8119
and i i think it's 89 um
i don't know what the address is it's
pretty important for me to know
social worker elizabeth griffin hall who
was contracted by the department of
social and health services
brings seven-year-old charlie and
five-year-old braden
on a supervised visit to see josh when
the boys run to him
he reportedly says that he has a
surprise
and immediately locks griffin hall out
of his house
but i think i need help right away he
he's
on a very short lease with cshs his cps
has been involved
and this is the craziest thing he looked
right at me and closed the door
are you there yes ma'am i'm just waiting
to know where you are okay
the 911 operator seemed to be very
callous
in in a hurry to get her off the phone
call didn't have any follow-up questions
regarding a lot of red flags
and i'd like to pull out of the driveway
because i smell gasoline and he won't
let me in
do you want to pull out of the driveway
because you smell gasoline that he won't
let you well
he won't let me in he won't let you out
of the driveway
he won't let me in the house
[Music]
getting so many calls over the course of
a day weeks years so
so much time on the job you start to
make assumptions and that was the
biggest problem
so you supervised and you're doing the
visit
yourself i supervise myself i'm the
supervisor here
okay how long will it be i don't know
man they have to respond to emergency
life-threatening situations first the
first available deputy
this could be life threatening after
griffin hall hangs up
josh's home suddenly bursts into flames
were you calling about the fire in the
8200
investigators would later learn josh
charlie and braden died as a result of
carbon monoxide poisoning
but prior to the explosion injuries to
the boy's necks and heads indicated
josh attacked his sons with a hatchet
all of this
occurring while griffin hall tried to
get help
she made a 911 call that call took about
six minutes
he didn't dispatch somebody for eight
minutes and after the dispatcher took 13
minutes for the police officers to
actually arrive on the scene
by that point the house was already
exploded the children were hacked up
and everybody was dead so the the fact
is
during the 911 call is when he should
have been making the dispatch to the
police officer on the street
providing the address and allowing the
police officer to decide the sense of
urgency of that call
not leaving it in the hands of the 911
dispatcher
the 911 dispatcher whom griffin hall
spoke with initially
would receive a reprimand and he himself
regretted the way
he handled the call and he said it was a
nightmare for him well guess what it was
a nightmare for that
entire family who lost those children
it's a living nightmare for
the department children family services
person who made the phone call
that she's going to have to live with
the rest of her life we
begged them not to let them go to that
last visitation
my wife asked them i asked them i called
up and said he will kill them
he will kill them and we had told them
that and
they said don't worry we got it covered
we have a supervisor there
and then they're gone how could josh
powell
kill his very own children in cold blood
and why at that moment at the time right
before he killed the kids
he was being ordered to take a
psychosexual evaluation
and to take a polygraph because they had
found incest cartoon porn
on his computer in utah so the walls
were closing in on him
he did and he was also disallowed on a
motion to return the kids
so and he knew there'd be a polygraph
dealing with the death of his wife the
murder of his wife
so it was almost like a state created
danger in our mind one time charlie said
to me around christmas time
just before they went were killed anyway
he said here's a he
had drawn me a picture of a wreath and
it had
a picture of his mom in the middle and
said help us find her
and he wanted me to get that to the
media so that
maybe somebody would start looking for
his mother he finally figured
that out that he would like to other
people to help look for his mother
and uh i just remember feeling oh my
gosh i hope you don't say this to your
father
because that would just set him off
terribly
in the aftermath of this tragedy the
focus turned to washington's department
of social and health services or
dshs to see if this horrific massacre
could have been prevented they had
basically plotted
and conspired to
get the children back with josh just so
that they didn't have to answer those
questions and
and deal with that parent that they
didn't like dealing with
they were negligent of doing the job
that they were paid to do
child protective services they weren't
predicting the children
then unbelievably the state agency cps
is supposed to be tasked with keeping
kids safe it's in their name
had home visitation with josh powell
with these two boys
where the boys were also potentially
witnesses to their moms from homicide
they were saying things like mommy went
with us on a camping trip didn't come
back
it was in a snowstorm in utah that was
his explanation for how she disappeared
when these kids were two and four
things like mommy's in a mine drawing a
stick figure of their mom in the trunk
of a car coming back etc
the cox's ultimately filed a wrongful
death lawsuit against
dshs arguing the state agency
could have saved their grandkids a jury
agreed and awarded susan's parents a
whopping
98 million dollar verdict all added up i
went
wow they cannot ignore this
award they can't just you know pay it
out of petty cash or something to be
done with it they're going to have to
address the issues
at the time of this recording a judge
has since reduced the payout to 32
million
and the cox's and state of washington
are in a legal fight over the damages
and a possible new trial
but one thing is clear changes in
procedure
are likely on the way in court they were
still arguing things that
were not in compliance with their
guidance so they're oblivious to it
eight years later they still haven't got
the message so
hopefully they're going to get the
message now in the end
we go back to the beginning with over a
decade after her disappearance
we still ask where is susan
my belief on why we don't know what
happened to susan is because
currently the father is dead stephen he
never decided to
take a plea deal when he went away to
divulge anything about the whereabouts
of susan
josh is also dead obviously and josh's
brother who was also
allegedly involved according to josh's
own sister
has passed away by suicide so with the
three people who we believe know what
happened to susan all being dead it's
i believe that's the reason we don't
know where her body is
the sad truth is unfortunately we may
never learn more about susan or why the
boys were murdered
but the cox's have made it their mission
to make sure nothing like this
happens again and with that
multi-million dollar verdict
hopefully that'll be the case that's all
we have for you on prime crime tonight
give us your comments on the susan cox
powell story on twitter and facebook
with the hashtag prime crime tonight
thank you for joining us and until next
time be safe
[Music]
[Music]
you